欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
没想到我们也有今天
亏为三个月
台股又创历史新高了
阿姨 恭喜
可是每一次创新高
大家就会担心
是不是又咕噜咕噜咕噜
要滚下来
应该不会啦
不是嘛
我们你看6月在担心
7月在担心
8月又要担心
现在创历史新高了
因为上一次创历史新高
也是收一个黑K
那今天更猛了
今天本来涨800多点
结果最后只涨80几点
所以今天拿了个800点的上影线
上影线800点
好家在
我觉得是量缩
量缩还可以接收
然后又要放假
所以大家今天可能钱卖卖
礼拜四放假前才拿到钱
提加二
所以我觉得还可以接受
下个礼拜再来看
因为台股可能有台股
自己中秋廉价的状况
可是如果以昨天晚上美股來說的話
是個個有表現猛將一大堆
是
好 所以我們就來解讀一下
如果今天只是一個
接錢賣壓的話
那接下來是不是好戲在後頭呢
今天48601
然後但是呢
我們先把節過了
因為看來今天確實有一些
接錢條件
但是掌力強
尤其是像CPU有好消息
半導體論壇這禮拜有好消息
還有傳習會等等的
都有一些支撐的力道
所以我覺得目前來說
息也升完了
最痛的那一刀也砍完了
對嘛 砍完了
然後油價也跌了
對 油價跌了
所以我覺得目前來說
先不管技術面會不會跌
至少我覺得事件性來講
應該短線上是比較少利空的
對 所以我們就來看一下
不只利空少
也有些利多的支持
沒錯META推出了
它最新的AI代理叫做MU-S
MU-S
沒錯
然後自己股價就漲了11%
為什麼 因為它在美國那邊的APP
免費下載是綁手
就是它好像推出快兩禮拜
然後就熔燈綁手
對 下載超過250萬次
所以這一件事情也讓大家覺得
AI其實是 還是需求很大的
而且它是什麼代理人
對 Asian AI
就幫你可以下訂單才夠
對 就大概是兩三個月前
我們有來講過的
就是之後你一支手機
你看到誰的演唱會了
他會幫你追蹤
幫我搶票
對 他會直接
你不用跟他講
對 你就給你設定好
先幫你追蹤
時間到他就自己買了
所以你就突然發現
信用卡就會跳通知
被扣款了
這樣好嗎
所以其實我覺得蠻方便
對嘛 只是你會學莫名其妙
你怎麼被扣錢
難怪亞馬遜其實不讓這個
代理人AI去他的網站買東西
是這樣子是不是
他說不知道後面是誰啊
有可能
對啊 如果這被入侵的話
應該蠻嚴重
好 那不管怎麼樣
我們發現這件事情又帶動了
AI的一個反攤
包含像是Meta
然後像Arm也自己漲起來了
Intel有12%
AMD也市值第一次達到了1兆美元
創歷史新高的股價
是的 所以整體來講
昨天的美股
尤其是半導體這一塊
它是全面紅
是
沒有錯 這也是帶動
今天台灣股市
為什麼可以開高的原因
那開高歸開高
盤中走低是走低
那納斯達克也創下
6月2號也來新高
所以目前來說
我覺得科技股
最近又重燃了一波火勢起來
是 幸好有美國科技股也跟上來
要不然我們自己在那裡吹風
挺冷的
是的 這一次終於不是
我們去給他們帶下
不是說向下去找他們
是他們上來找我們了
沒錯 沒錯
再來另外一個
還有光通訊的大展
有開幕在歐洲
是的 跟Lumantum
有高通 有康寧
秀了D2D的互聯
瞄準的就是AI橫向擴展的架構
所以這一些東西
基本上大家就稍微自己看一下
那图也截在这边
因为它这边东西
都是比较技术面上
技术产业的东西
就是他们自己绣一些肌肉出来
那这年来讲
其实对于目前整个CPU的族群性
我觉得应该都还是一些
持续性的利多
只不过最近的CPU的走势
有一点分析
然后老的CPU稍微没有这么有活力
年轻一点的CPU比较有活力
我们等下下一段会讲
所以这个是近期又有一个
相关的CPU的利多
对 好
其实主要往上美股的CPU
也是有反应的
是的 所以我觉得CPU来讲
应该都还是可以
持续好好去关注的
那再来看到另外一个呢
就是刚刚提到了国外的
那我们讲一下我们国内的
台积电要拼先进封装
它也兼顾到国外
因为北美的OIP论坛
也要展开就在这里办
所以这边应该台积电
和相关技术的东西
会很多才对
所以应该还是持续会有一些
看有沒有大家解讀利多的訊息
可是今天台積電收最低
沒辦法 今日最低
是的
可是我們的VCC
有說我們股價要趕快追上聯發科
請問是要上去追到發哥5000還是發哥要下來找台積電應該要上去吧如果他要5000那就是台积电要翻倍就是台积电当然希望往上追
所以台积电如果要翻倍
那我们台股至少
指数也要涨个80%吧
我们先看3000好不好
翻倍真的是
所以目前来说
他有纠团设先进封装的中心
会在高雄白浦的
白浦产业园区
然后会号召本土的设备
跟材料的业者去做进驻
基本上还是持续
一条龙的供应链
所以我觉得这一些未来
应该都还是
从里面找商机
就是不只是台积电
台积电跟他的好朋友们
应该都可以好好注意一下
这个是持续上
经这几天的一些新闻
给大家观察一下
你会发现AI相关的都反应
就是大家都往正向表态
所以我觉得也是真的很神奇
你看上礼拜
上上礼拜我们还在讲
那个要暂缓发展
而且很闷
就是成交量很萎缩
又担心AI 又担心升息
然后今天油价跌很重嘛
油价那个什么
西德州剩95块
对 原本100多
然后那个布兰特也是
跌到100元附近
所以整个科技股就飙起来了
瞬间好像利空通通不见
对 就一周的时间
那台湾股市呢
我们可以看到
今天是48601
盘中有突破了
这个6月的历史新高
但是收盘价其实呢
是没有突破的
那就等于是挑战失败
这样说挑战失败啊
挑战失败
对那挑战失败过程中还怎么样
还拉了一个800点左右的上影线
所以这个短线上
应该就会是一个明确要整理的讯号
那不过这个整理讯号我们有说嘛
高档如果再配报大量
那可能就是涨完了的讯号
上次就有一点这个味道
是的
那可是呢
这一次其实是没有报大量的
这一次还算合理的量
对所以我觉得还可以接受
但是单纯就这一根来讲
我个人觉得短期
应该也是要出现整理的讯号
不过这个整理呢
一方面今天是礼拜二嘛
那今天卖股票礼拜四领得到钱
对礼拜四可以拿回钱
对可是你明天卖跟后天卖
都基本上是节后才能领到钱
报股过节
报钱过节
是的所以大家可能会在今天
会有做了一些节前的
T加2的卖压调整
那一方面就是有些交易者呢
喜欢是创新高开始卖股票
对所以有一些获利卖压也好
或者说有一些节前的调整也好
那造就了今天有一个上影线
我觉得是还可以接受的
那成交量 重点是成交量
没有爆得很夸张
还是在一兆左右
那我觉得这个状态之下
就还算OK
那OK过程中
我们基本上上影线嘛
所以还是要注意整理
那有几个位置
大家可以稍微观察一下
首先是这个前高
这个前高是47600
其实就大概300点左右
因为今天47800嘛
所以大概差200到300点
那这个位置是原本的压力区
所以突破转支撑
那再来就是均线
接下来要上完了
上完过程会形成一些支撑
就是有一些助长的效果
那只要碰到了一些支撑的支撑区
或者说关键的一些上完均线
有出现了止跌的讯号
那我觉得合理都有机会
再重新挑战这个高点
那如果再做突破
那这个行情就是持续定高了
所以目前来说我觉得短线确实
可能明后天成价量
应该会稍微萎缩一点
因为要放假了
那刚好来一个价跌量缩
然后开始酝酿可能放假后的新行情
所以下礼拜只要出现一些
更好的讯号出现
其实我觉得应该都是站在买方
对 那目前来说
只会看短线要休息
但长线是多头
我觉得应该没有问题
再来另外是贵买
贵买今天也很可惜
都上影线
但是收盘价确实占上了
这个410次
对 所以我会认为
它是一个相形的突破
那这应该都会是
对长线来讲是好事
当然都上影线
所以上影线我觉得
短线要休息应该都没问题
应该都
合理的
对啦 几率比较高
那整理的过程
只要不要有一个
突然明天补大量 1.5兆下來
那這個就不行了
可是應該不太會
所以我覺得就是
這兩天沉澱一下
因為要放假
可能我覺得交易的活絡度也會降低
那等放完假之後
再來看一下量等跟形態上
有沒有更進一步向上去做發展
反而是今天一開盤
那個800點有把我嚇一跳
大家好猛喔
對啊 很可惜
尾盤其實賣壓真的滿重的
另外一看就台積電
台大電說錯了
台下店呢
在昨天來一個紅K
這紅K很重要 為什麼
這個是6月
一次 兩次 三次
到了這一次第五次
終於站上季線
所以我覺得是一個
非常重要的一個訊號
就是這60天買的人呢
終於賺錢了
那賺錢了呢
這裡做突破
剩下挑戰這個地方
這個地方是一個頸線位置
所以這裡要做突破
這WD就確立了
那我覺得已經打兩隻腳了
剩下是高點要去做突破
它都低檔有量耶
然後低檔有人想要買它
果然是好公司
是的 所以我覺得它這邊
開始有在展現台達電
應該要有的樣子
因為開始Q是也要出貨了
對 所以我覺得
之前的一些兩率問題
或者說出貨低延的問題
應該要開始慢慢消化掉
再來應該是光寶科
光寶科這一波走勢比台達電來的強很多先創新高的是它是 那不過在後面這一阵子也是一路整理到270块开始足底那今天很可惜来到300又开高走低
但我会觉得这边
已经出现了一个开始足底的讯号
所以在这个位置上
我觉得光宝科上升趋势线跌破了
那开始走整理
但周围里来到这个位置
应该也要在这边做足底
所以我觉得有一个赚赔比的
或者说非常好抓停损的位置出现了
就是270跌破
因为跌破这边就是导N型
可是如果这边没跌破
那后面我觉得光宝科的产业的状态
应该不会输台下电
对 所以我觉得后续应该是值得期待
这个是两个电源的全资股
随便跟大家稍微分享一下
技术面上的状态
好 当然台积电今天收的比较低
是有点可惜
但是也把空间等于让出来给大家
后续还是很值得期待
也可能是有这个提款效应的关系
所以广告回来我们会继续聊下去
有这么多的好消息
有一个事情很特别
Intel为什么大涨
有人说Intel是因为跟友达结盟做CPU
我第一次听到有台湾的厂商跟美股
就是合作是涨在美股身上
当然友达今天也很强
所以延伸这个话题我们来看一下
到底整体的CPU状况如何呢
OK来吧
这个很奇妙的事情
當然我不覺得單純是因為
友達和Intel要合作
Intel大漲啦
但是因為確實友達也很強
Intel也很強
是的
這Intel昨天12%的漲
對啊
我們是漲停板
沒錯
所以我覺得
可是我覺得應該也沒有
因為昨天半導體也很強
對啦
所以我說不應該只是因為這樣
可能剛好有這個新聞出現
好 那有傳出來
Intel吸手友達要強攻CPU
先進封裝這一塊
所以又有一個利多給了友達
那友達這兩天的股價
都是漲停板的
那我們今天來講的
剛剛有提到
最近的老CPU
除了可能全新之外
那普遍的
譬如說什麼波羅威
聯亞
或者是說這種上全 光盛
其實股價當然前面有反彈
但是現階段比較溫吞一點點
可是有一些新的CPU
開始在陸續強勢起來
就是擴散出來
甚至說它的股價比較便宜
幾十塊
沒錯 什麼光頂 頂圓
真的很猛
對 然後還有什麼聯誼光
所以反而是這一波的新的CPU
反而股價比較強一點
擴散效應又來了
對 所以大家反而還是會喜歡新的題材
因為可能有達意轉型
台表科轉型
穩帽是沒有轉型
但穩帽也就還是
近期的表現還可以
林光通也是有說要做FAEU
所以股價也是底部出現了一個
兩根左右的漲停板
那我們今天來跟大家講的就是前面這四位
稍微來看一下目前的一些題材
跟技術面上的走勢
那友達呢
其實他本來就跟群創是做一樣面板
那其實他們本業也有利多
因為中國這邊也傳要漲價
然後他們的價動率降低
所以呢不只是供給變少
然後單價也變高
所以以本業來講應該還不錯
那再來另外一個呢
就是群創他有FOP、LP跟CPU
那友達呢
就比較偏向CPU一點點
友達又傳可能跟台積電合作
是啊
中科廠可能會賣給台積電
3.5跟7.5
然后再来是
群创是强上半年
然后友达反而题材
在下半年之后发酵
一样的题材
一模一样
跟台积电合作
先后的顺序
现在是强在友达上
所以大家如果你去看群创
群创其实是被季线压着
然后股价是稍微
比较温吞一点点
可是友达就因为有一些利多
然后又卖场又一些借钱
有借很多钱
然后跟英特尔又合作
所以股价最近的表现
这两天成交的
应该都是台股最大
那它今天创下了历史的最大量
你会关心这个事情吗
有涨停我就不关心
对
今天幸好它有锁住
有有有打开过
中间一直开开关关
洗了一百多万张的成交量
没错
这个太吓人了
所以我觉得接下来走势
应该都还是盘中都要注意震荡
一百多万张
对 我觉得隔日冲跟当冲
一定超多人
这个这么好冲
量这么大
不过至少技术面上
N字形
然后也突破了
今年7月的高点
所以我觉得形态上
又收涨停
应该没有太多问题
那不过短线当然
越来越多人知道
它的这个非常活泼
力多在哪里
是 所以我觉得交易的人会变多
那就要看一下筹码的变化
跟形态上有没有转弱
譬如说明天
这成交量这么粗
然后呢开高走低黑K
这么粗是要200万
太可怕了吧
不要说不可能啊
它最近这么吸睛
然后如果有上影线
那记得做一些调整
好 大家一定要留意哦
对 没错
所以我覺得目前來說
有答兩根漲停
應該N字形
大家就可以再稍微關注一下
是 應該給你一個獎狀
忘記了 上次有講
那再來另外一個就是台表科
怎麼會輪到他
台灣表面黏著科技
我們都叫他表哥
好像表哥以前股性很不舒服
沒錯 其實他就是做代工對 他就是我把東西給你原物料要給你我幫你把這些東西焊接到板子上面嘛對那目前來說台表科呢有接到Cohenium跟AOI的訂單
是
對 那這些都是
毛利率比它本業來的高
那另外一個呢
它也有接到美光跟
常新存儲的訂單
是
就是要記憶體封裝嘛
它也幫你把東西都黏上去
這些東西呢
毛利率也不低
你怎麼會發現它咧
這問題非常好
因為表哥的範圍
本來就很廣
年年年年年嘛
对 因为表哥
其实在前面古载之前
他那一波
其实炒的题材是一样的
他有凶过一段时间
对 他那个时候
就有接到那个AOI的嘛
Cohenron的嘛
然后再来
就还有像类似正文嘛
网通那一块
也都有类似接到
一样的题材
我觉得形态上
今天这个涨停
也出现了一个
N字形的走势
对 所以我觉得
这边应该都还是
一个不错的状态
那成交量也放出来了
是
对 所以我觉得
都可以持续观察一下
如果有回落均线跟上
大家可以去注意一下新的买店
是
就是表哥的部分
再另一个就是这个瑞萱
他也是比较有趣的
是
对 他之前也是从那种十多块
就忽然狂喷说有CPU
没错
那这一阵子呢
瑞萱他其实之前也是做
电子消费性代工
所以也没什么钱可以赚
显示器啊
对
那不过这一次呢
传说有跟
不是传啦
就是新闻有写
就是有做到波若威的shufflebox
沒錯 幫忙它做代工
那後面這個對於它營收貢獻來講
應該會值得期待
因為它的營收其實
以本業來講是比較疲弱一點的
對 那這一波修正
目前到這個地方
這邊也是一個N字形
那到這個地方呢
到這裡為止
其實都還維持一個上升趨勢的結構
可是短線上確實在這個地方
遇到了一些這個阻力了
然後今天跌破五日均線
所以呢 這邊開始在震盪的時候
前滴要守好
那這邊走一個成立
那走成立前滴如果有守好
那上去的时候
这边要做突破
做突破这个形态
就会打出来
新的多方就会继续做延伸
所以上阵趋势还在
这个地方呢
短线要做一些挑战
看能不能挑战过去
挑战过去就安全了
对 所以目前来说
瑞萱也遇到一些成立
那这两天黑K都亮缩
所以我觉得也还可以接受
那就等这个均线慢慢跟上
有没有一些助长的效果
这个是瑞萱的部分
也是偏转机股
没错
这个也是转机题材股
另外一个呢就是稳茂
好 這個就比較正統了
對不對
這個零花音等等的
然後也逐漸從這個
傳統的消費性電子
走向AI領域了
是的 這個之前
以三五族來講的話
其實聯亞應該是最強的
不過這一波是全新最強
而且全新的股價是超過文貌的
這個也是滿有趣的
本來文貌是先領先的
是的 後面就發現
其實就有比較不一樣一點
可能全新跟聯亞在漲的是
是所谓的零化音
比較純一點點
那穩帽就沒有到純的零化音
那目前來說
它有相關的化合物半導體
微博通訊
有光源鍵的這個代工
那養豬的都賣掉了
對 之前嘛
那就是比較舊的題材
是 對 目前來說
整個表現上
已經開始進入一個量產
所以營收應該有機會激增
然後一成以上
跟毛利率應該會維持在三成以上
其實我覺得都還算是有在成長的
再來就是技術面的部分
目前短線上聯亞是一個明確的休息的走勢
然後全新是高檔整理
不過穩帽這邊有慢慢拉出一個N字形的走勢
這裡是第一段
大家一起漲的時候
然後開始走休息
然後這個時候又是大家一起漲的時候
然後全新就自己上去了
穩帽就在這邊走整理
整理的過程碰到了一樣上升趨勢的位置
這兩點連成一線就開始有一個新的行情
那這個行情來到這個地方
它今天收盤價其實是有佔上前高的
所以N字型應該有機會
繼續向上去做延伸
但是波度就會比較緩一點
我覺得穩帽就反而是
如果你成本拉得比較開的
是
那我覺得抱起來還滿舒服的
就是它整理的時候
至少它整個趨勢慣性
大家非常明顯
也就是說如果你要做一個
停利或停損
那就是月線做跌破
然後呢
或者是高檔的時候
走回落有爆了一個大量
再去做調整就好
目前的形態
我覺得都沒有太多問題
大家可以去參考一下
都是多方的結構
好
所以等于是有这种属于
有点中高价的
然后像刚刚讲的
几十块的转机股
反正本益比都那么高了
那几十块的转机
应该也很有吸引力才对
没错
所以大家如果看基本面
其实有点难做CPU
没错
大家可以看一下量价
跟技术面上的形态
好 所以这边的话
喜欢CPU的朋友
其实CPU有节奏的
先反弹的可能会是
所谓的老CPU
一线CPU像联雅就领军了
可是接下来就会有扩散效应
這幾天雖然台股創歷史新高
可是不是台積電帶動的
反而很多中小型的低價股
非常的活潑喔
大家可以著亮的試試看
因為進場的成本跟壓力
會比較低一點點
可是他們的基本面不好參考
所以一定要看他們的技術型態
來做操作
那如果需要今天所有的圖卡資料
歡迎訂閱一下我們趙華艾倫說的
YouTube頻道喔
我們會把它